what's up everybody Walter Bernays yank
here with Ayane Wade and have the ruse
we are here in Metropolis Illinois for
the 40th annual Superman celebration and
there's a lot of stuff going on around
here it's like a carnival and comic-con
combined basically and today we're
counting down the top 5 that Superman
the animated series episode so while
we're doing that we're gonna show you
around here so let's get to the
countdown with number 5 right now number
5 Apocalypse Now parts 1 & 2 from season
2 Darkseid and his forces from
apocalypse finally make their move to
attack and conquer earth standing in
their way is Superman metropolis is
special Crimes Unit led by Dan Turpin
and a mysterious ally named Orion who
has arrived early to warn kal-el of dark
sides coming I'm going into spoilers for
all these episodes so you've been warned
sans the arrival of Supergirl this was
the finale of season 2 and it pushed
things to a new level in terms of action
and emotion we're introduced to Darkseid
son Orion who was given up as an infant
in the exchange of errors to guarantee
peace between apocalypse and new Genesis
in fact they delve into the entire
history of these two warring worlds with
a great scene in part one it added depth
to some of the characters and situations
that were previously introduced all
while doing it in a quick enough way
that didn't detract from the main plot
of the episode Orion is an awesome
character that we get a little more of
in the to Justice League series
Steppenwolf also shows up looking
somehow more realistic than in the
Justice League movie but when Darkseid
arrives on earth he's all intimidation
Michael Ironside does a fantastic job
voicing him and he's great throughout
the series as Superman's main physical
threat perhaps his most heinous act in
the entire show was the cold-blooded
murder of Dan Turpin savor your moment
drive Superman but remember the tree has
its price
[Music]
Turpin was a featured side character in
the first two seasons who was modeled
after legendary comic creator Jack Kirby
among many other contributions to the
medium Kirby created the new God so it
was appropriate to give him a big
send-off in this episode the image of
Superman standing at his grave is among
the best and most heartbreaking moments
in the series goodbye old friend in the
end the world didn't really need a
Superman just a brave one
we are in front of the metropolis tent
where Brandon Ralph is answering
questions for fans right now and behind
us is this amazing mural with all the
Superman's but - Henry camp also do with
that what you will hum but let's keep
the countdown going with number four
number four the late mr. Kent from
season two Clark Kent is dead or so the
world thinks after using his
investigative reporter skills to try and
save an innocent man from death row a
bomb is planted on Clark's car which
blows up and sends it crashing into the
ocean with Kent still inside with a
witness seeing all this go down Clark
can't rise from the vehicle without his
identity as Superman being revealed and
so Clark Kent is pronounced dead also
destroyed was the evidence that was
going to clear the inmate Superman must
now find out how to protect his identity
while saving that inmate and discover
who is behind the hit on Kent this is a
very different type of episode for
Superman the animated series the
structure is different and boy does it
get dark I really loved how much we get
to see Clark Kent the reporter in this
it's not an aspect of the character that
we get much of in this show and this
episode proved we could have used more I
suppose I could have flown to the
governor as Superman and given in the
disk but that could have raised some
awkward questions maybe there was some
ego involved too I wanted this to be
Clark's victory not Superman the
narrations are well done here and
present an interesting way to tell the
story we even get a peek at the inner
duality of Superman and a secret
identity it just can't be Clark anymore
but I am Clark I need to be Clark I'd go
crazy if I had to be Superman all the
time the episode ends with Superman
saving the wronged inmate from the gas
chamber yes the gas chamber and we even
see the final moments of life of the
crooked cop who framed the accused
seeing this ending with the cherry
Superman theme following it is so
creepily bizarre he's Superman
[Music]
cheese hey we're outside the Superman
Museum right now inside the phone booth
where I am and this museum super cute
it's only $5 to get in open 7 days a
week but we're gonna keep this lets
going with number three number three
brave new metropolis from season two dr.
Emil Hamilton has created an
interdimensional gateway to try and
match the power of the Phantom Zone
projector Lois gets closer to check it
out when she's unexpectedly transported
onto a parallel earth this world's
lowest lane was killed by inter-gang
which changed Superman drastically more
dictator than protector he's joined
forces with Lex Luthor to make
metropolis safe again unfortunately the
city has become a very strict police
state with many people living
underground to try and overthrow the
authoritarian Superman when this world's
man of tomorrow sees Lois again it sets
off a chain reaction that will change
this alternate earth for better or worse
this was an honorable mention in my top
5 best alternate versions of Superman
video and it is definitely one of the
best episodes of the series deep shades
of grey are present across the whole
episode and what lets Superman down this
path is almost understandable it
presents him in a more closed off yet
vulnerable way when Lois shows back up
after being killed off on this earth
Superman tries to explain his new
attitude for too long I fooled myself
into thinking I was doing a simple clean
up job that if I did enough good people
would follow my example I didn't realize
it was a war and suddenly you were a
casualty of that war the music in this
episode is fantastic as well it really
sets the tone for a moody and
fascinating character study with Lois
pushing the action we also get to see
the seeds planted for her and Superman's
developing relationship
[Music]
guys we found Batman and a Superman here
it's truly a magical place
but before we get to number two Superman
has something else to share with us
well everybody out there on Facebook
please if you would check it out
heroes for kids which is out of
Perryville Missouri please it's our
charity group it's a non-profit thank
you awesome all right let's get to
number two number two world's finest
parts one through three from season two
Batman and Superman
finally team up in this three-part
adventure The Joker has come to
Metropolis and combines forces with Lex
Luthor to kill Superman
Batman is not far behind as Bruce Wayne
has business in the super city The Dark
Knight and the Man of Steel clashed with
each other while looking for the Joker
and things get even more complicated
when Bruce starts a romantic
relationship with Lois Lane there's no
love lost between the two crime
fighter's but can they coexist long
enough to stop Joker and Luthor from
doing irreparable damage to Metropolis
some of you may be familiar with this
three-parter as the batman superman
movie which it was released as on video
later but it was first presented as
episodes in Superman and was a milestone
for the DCAU
I don't need to say much about this one
to get most fans interested Batman and
Superman the animated series collided
with a great tit-for-tat back and forth
between our two heroes and it's so much
fun to watch their chemistry is
phenomenal and developed more and more
as the years went on another note I
wanted to mention was how perfect for
each other Bruce and Lois scene these
characters just gelled here and I really
wanted to see more of them together I
think maybe even more than Catwoman or
Talia Lois was Bruce's best match in
this continuity and it would have been
an awesome twist to see them as a couple
for a while in any case this
three-parter is just amazing it's a must
watch for fans of these characters
[Music]
everybody before we get to number one
I'm gonna talk about these awesome walk
of hope Superman symbols that are all
across the street here in the main
square all the different symbols of
Superman are talked about and have a
little blurb about them on the bottom
there so it's pretty cool to see how the
logo has changed over the years but I
know what you want to see the number one
best Superman the animated series
episode let's get to it
right now in the number one best episode
of Superman the animated series is
legacy parts 1 & 2 from season 3
Superman has been brainwashed by granny
goodness into thinking he's the adopted
son of Darkseid for months kal-el went
from planet to planet doing his father's
will when Darkseid sends him to conquer
and rule earth the people who always saw
Superman as a symbol of hope see that
that same man has come to destroy and
pervert everything he once stood for
this two-parter can stand up next to any
DCAU episode it's that good we basically
see the fall of Superman as he loses
control while under the influence of
Darkseid
they take the characters to new places
and really push the envelope the ending
battle with dark side and Superman's
lingering feelings of dread and guilt
push this one to the top it's a tragic
ending to a great series that explored
Superman in a way that felt familiar yet
fresh apparently there was supposed to
be a fourth season that dealt with the
aftermath of this incident
Superman was to somehow regain the
public's trust we never got to see that
directly because the production team was
assigned to Batman Beyond but this event
was brought up as a major story point in
Justice League Unlimited this series is
considered among many to feature some of
the best Superman stories period I won't
disagree it may not have reached the
heights of Bruce Tim's Batman the
Animated Series but this show should not
be looked over at more than did justice
to the Man of Steel while expanding the
DCAU to incorporate a whole world of
characters those characters and Superman
himself were pushed even further in
Justice League and Justice League
Unlimited both of which I have top 5
best episodes of you can check out right
here this week on my personal channel
you can find out where these honorable
mentions ranked in a brand new episode
of the countdown continue also Superman
the anime
Cirie's takes on the original Fletcher
brothers Superman cartoon and a new
installment of my vs. series going up
soon if you want to hear more about our
experience in Metropolis illinois make
sure you stay tuned for a video covering
the Man of Steel's hometown hey hope you
guys enjoyed this super countdown we
were really having fun out here at
metropolis Illinois you can always hit
us up on social media to let us know
what you'd like to see next on top 5
Walter worth that for you you can find
me on Twitter at awesome underscore
Walter and on Facebook awesome Walter
beep awesome and then Heather worth
Africa you can find me on Twitter
Instagram or twitch and you can find me
on Facebook Instagram or Twitter awesome
we are going to go explore some more go
meet some superheroes until next time
we'll see ya
[Music]
[Applause]
you